as we approach
the day that honors your father
what are the feelings that arise as we
get closer to that time i'm
unfortunately i'm wired to be task
oriented first
um and so
you know i kind of spend the day going
through the motions i have to go through
and i'm not always in tune with what's
happening uh in my feelings during that
time period because i think if i did
that it would probably hinder
my ability to be effective because it's
still hard i mean you got to realize
um i told somebody the other day we we
really haven't been able to
quote unquote bury
our parents i mean i work at the
institution where they are entombed in a
crypt
um a side by side crypt and and so it's
it's right there with you you know on a
daily basis they're very much alive you
know because people continue to
refer to to my dad
constantly you know in just about almost
every
issue in the universe
and so um you know i just try to keep
all of my energy and attention to focus
next year
marks the 60th anniversary of your
father's i have a dream speech
how do you plan
how do you plan on celebrating um and
what how do you continue your father's
legacy
you know i haven't even thought about
that because that next year i turned 60
myself so wow it's that close
um
you know i i don't know what what what
that celebration uh will look like um
i'll have to think about that but
you know
i see my my role in responsibility is to
bring to fruition uh some of the things
that he spoke about for instance
uh in 1964 when he received the nobel
peace prize he talked about
um
the philosophy and
strategy of non-violence immediately
he suggested that it immediately become
the subject of study
and serious experimentation in every
field of human conflict by no means
excluding nations
and we at the king center now have an
opportunity to help the process of
manifesting those words through our new
um e-learning non-violence online
non-violence 365 online experience you
know you talk about how he affected so
many people in so many places around the
world and i think of
barack obama's inauguration and
sitting watching barack obama sitting on
the steps of the lincoln memorial
listening to a band from ireland
you too sing a song about your father in
that moment and it probably is one of my
favorite moments of e.t but it speaks to
the worldwide reach of what your father
did and what he meant and also how it
has permeated the entertainment business
do you have a moment a thing
that you love to watch
a portrayal of your father
or a song that
um
is your favorite you know that's that's
you know god i mean that's so hard
because yeah you know when you go on
youtube
it's not like he has this one thing
that's just it
a lot of his stuff is life
we have seen so many different actors
portray your father and
do you have a do you have a favorite
actor i think back all the way to paul
uh paul winfield
yeah or winfield um and people talk
about david o'yellow now but do you have
a favorite you know playing dr king has
to be kind of eerie i can't even i
wouldn't want to be in those person's
shoes because it's uh
you know when very good actors
you know they they learn
the character i mean when you start
talking about learning dr king you're
taking on some moral weight
into your life
it's pretty serious what did you think
of david o yellow's performance in selma
i think he did an exceptional job you
know um coming from the uk it always
amazes me how they can change their
voice
like that and so yeah i think he did an
exceptional job that means protest that
means march that means disturb the peace
that means jail
that means risk and that is hard
[Applause]
we will not wait any longer
give us the vote
what did you think of when you saw the
selma cast and oprah and so many people
walking across the edmond pettis bridge
when you saw that cast and everyone
walking across and recreating those
steps for me it was just an important
moment for our time because it's so far
so long ago and just bringing that to
life today and making it real for people
i think was was what really touched me
what did it mean for your father to have
the support of folks like harry
belafonte and um
poitiers that were there to help
you know really help him when he needed
financial assistance what did that mean
it was a burden lifter i mean when when
my father decided to go to jail for
instance in birmingham
everybody was concerned and counseling
him you know not to go because you know
you're the face you're the leader you're
the one that can get out there and help
raise money to give people you know the
bail money to get people out of jail and
um
you know he had the faith and belief
that something would happen
you know he ended up being locked up
solitary confinement that's where he
wrote the famous letter from the
birmingham jail but it was had belafonte
and others that he you know solicited uh
where the funds came through next month
marks the 20th anniversary of the rosa
parks story
what did you think of your brother
taking the role in that
in that story when dexter played yeah
with dexter
ladies and gentlemen
the heroine of our finest hour
mrs rosa parks
well that was funny to me i just say
that it was funny to me
yeah yeah
yeah it had to be hard too i never had
that conversation with him but it had to
be
hard because
he didn't come to y'all and say hey i'm
going to play daddy no no but i'm saying
you know
i was younger
so it's just where i am today
i tend to want to ask more questions
right um right and i just want you know
what is it really like
because he looks like our father he's
the one that really looks like him spit
an image we recently lost sidney poitier
and your father said this about him in
1967 um
he is a man of great depth a man of
great social concern a man who is
dedicated to human rights
and freedom
what did you think he meant
i think he was talking about a man of
integrity who
um
saw his role in the industry not just as
an actor
but as an influencer and an inspirer
and
you know he
he took
each one of those roles he played uh was
very significant to the unfolding story
uh of our community
and uh so you know i think he was
tapping into that
and acknowledging it so you know
he's missed
certainly and will be missed um
actors like that uh
i won't say they're once in a lifetime
but they're
rare um
and we thank god for what he read he
opened up so many doors
for so many people yup and he did it
with such dignity
and grace
and uh you know he did not let anything
stop him
yeah
and despite the conditions black history
month is coming up and
i mean i feel like black history should
be celebrated every day because it's
american history but
how do you celebrate black history month
and how should we as a nation look at
black history month you know
most times i get invited a lot of to a
lot of different places to speak and i
try not to confine my energy to it being
black history month i'm aware of it it's
because for me it's what you said you
know
it's a it's all year round
yeah and i always say that the people
don't confine me to a black history time
period to come and give us what i can
say is relevant march april may june
july the rest of the year
um and so you know we you know we have a
lot of work to do and all of the efforts
now that i'm concerned about under the
banner
you know of crt
um
you know is is is extremely
troubling
and i think we are sleeping on it
not paying enough attention to it
um and we got to start paying attention
bernice you know this is entertainment
tonight so i gotta ask you is there a
favorite movie can you go back and think
of a favorite movie that your father was
portrayed in selma was good you know i
was on the set
of the one king
the one that paul winfield assistant you
were there
yeah i was on the set because my sister
played rosa parks what do you remember
about being on the set though of king
wow god you know i i
it's kind of hard for me to recall all
of it i had something being on the set
that may not be you know i was i was
young
i'm gonna tell this story
so uh one night me and my sister went
into the production room you know they
had a lot of stuff in their refrigerator
and everything
and i used to watch everybody on on the
set you know uh
and i could be honest about this
probably uh white men at the time they
were going to refrigerate it maybe you
know they would get this beer and they
would just drink and drink and drink and
drink it
so i decided while we were in the
production room that night i'm gonna go
in the refrigerator let's see what this
beer is about
i just popped it like i was getting
ready to drink it coca-cola i drank it
out there
i couldn't take it
now that may not be the best memory but
that sticks with me to this day on that
set but i was honored to be there uh to
to witness um
um sicily oh my god may she rest in
peace and paul winfield both of them
um you know play my my parents but i
have something i want to share with you
i'm i'm still so we talk about
entertainment i'm still learning i i
don't have a song to play but i have a
little
you know
harmonica
[Music]
that's for your entertainment tonight
[Music]